achever son marathon alsacien en charge
de la concertation sur l'avenir
institutionnel de l'alsace la ministre a
rencontré les élus locaux
quel bilan tires tu l de ces deux jours
d'échangés regardez cet entretien de la
ministre avec caroline keller j'ai
constaté ce désir d'alsace très fort
cette collectivité d'alsace souhaite
aussi qu'on prenne en compte les
spécificités alsacienne transfrontalière
rhénane européenne
et avec eux des volonté de négocier je
dis bien sa volonté de négocier avec les
autres niveaux de collectivités
territoriales que sont d'une part la
région et d'autre part je dirais le bloc
communal quel va être l'étape suivante
où les étapes suivantes parce que
globalement finalement le calendrier
tout de même assez contraint alors il va
y avoir des équipes administratives qui
vont travailler ensemble aussi bien des
représentants des collectivités
territoriales régionales départementales
de la collectivité collectivités que
sont les intercommunalités pour
travailler sur ce qui est essentiel pour
eux c'est à dire les compétences et nous
nous sommes mis d'accord pour entrer
dans cette discussion par les
compétences est ce que vous vous êtes
penché sur la question de 2013 pour ne
pas reproduire les erreurs assure il
faut tirer les leçons de ce qui s'est
passé en 2013 et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous pensons tous maintenant
qu'il ne faut pas se braquer sur les
affaires institutionnelles au sens
administratif du terme qu'il faut
rentrer comme je les ai dit tout à
l'heure par les compétences car c'est ça
le coeur de l'enjeu et il est évident
que nous sommes mis d'accord sur la
méthode et que cette méthode va se
mettre en place et que elle aboutira jeu
j'en suis quasi certaine à la création
d'une collectivité territoriales
alsaciennes
la ministre va poursuivre ses
consultations elle recevra les
parlementaires alsaciens à paris le 26
septembre au chef